what was it like the day you got like
the call or the news like hey
you're gonna be in the next mortal
kombat movie i had auditioned for it
um you know earlier in the year months
months before i ever got the call
and i never in a million years thought i
was going to get it so i'll be totally
honest
i i went into the audition going let's
just get this over and done with so we
can
we can both get on with our lives and um
and i forgot all about it i really
really did and i was in pre-production
on a film that i was directing in sydney
and uh i got a call it must have been
like three or four months later
and i go hey do you remember that mortal
kombat thing you went for it i went
vaguely oh yeah what was it again
and they go oh well you should you
better brush up on it because you got it
all right what what what and i was just
that's how surprising it was for me that
was
one audition with the casting director
three
four months earlier and i assume they
they asked a bunch of other people who
said no
or had scheduling conflicts or something
and they ended up with it
but yeah that was it man that's how i
got it i was very surprised
yeah uh i mean laugh out
every time i laughed out loud in that
movie was a kano line i know i think
it's just
hilarious we were like that on set we
couldn't keep straight faces when he was
around
which was the whole time my character
was on screen and i'm so serious in the
movie and i was like this is not helping
my course
but i was uh i was actually in greece
it was awesome i was on vacation and i
was like
having a moment where i was like oh god
i just can't wait to get back and i've
spent so much money here and i
really need another job and i was the
same though i put myself on tape i was
actually
away um for work at the time so i
couldn't go in to audition so i'd put
myself on self tape
sent it off didn't hear anything i think
it would have been about same thing
three or four months
and then i get this call and i was in
mykonos
and it was my i actually turned my phone
off because i was just enjoying life
and i had emails coming through i had my
my manager was um messaging me on
instagram they were coming from all
directions voicemails being like where
are you
and finally i answered and they're like
you have this call with the director of
mortal kombat remember that film and i
was like yeah of course i remember
and then we facetimed and i got it it
was and now you're sonia blade
i know it's so awesome when you guys
played mortal kombat who was the
character you always played us
mine's boring it was sonia because she's
the baddest
[ __ ] out there mine was so new too good
i love it
uh my mind was on your three um
i don't remember actually i i have a
feeling he's probably lucky
to be honest i think it was liu kang he
felt like the cool
the coolest one as a kid i seem to
recall yeah
josh did you improv a lot of your lines
or were those all on the page
there's a lot of improv it was a lot of
improv
and that that's thanks to simon mccoy
who gave me
the room to be able to do that and that
helped me find the character as much as
anything else
but um you know i i would i would often
give a scripted
version of it and then just go look do
you mind if i we play around a little
bit
um so i think i think what ends up in
the film is quite is quite a lot of
improv
um but yeah so uh i was able to
[ __ ] around with it a bit yeah and every
every line
that he delivers in the movie you gotta
believe there were like
ten other ones yeah or an alt on that
one that we were all just dying laughing
at as well so i don't even know how they
would sift through that and pick a favor
we would like crying half the time
laughing it must have been
so much material yeah because that's
true i would just
i would just i would just go let me do
another one i got something else so get
some
let's just do a million dollars
oh my god they'll release the looks yeah
that's funny
well this movie grants us with the one
thing that every mortal kombat fan wants
to see and those are the finishers the
fatalities
um so when you actually see yours like
play out on screen
what was how did you react
oh yeah oh for me it's funny the
uh yeah i mean it's brilliant you see it
you see it obviously a bit in the
trailer so it's a big spoil a bit
um i think when i had said to friends
when i first got the job i was doing
mortal kombat
i i would say overwhelmingly the biggest
comment was oh do you get to rip
someone's heart out
and i was like i think i do man um it's
and so
to be able to do that was
i mean yeah it was more it was fun is it
to say the least but it was
it was really satisfying uh and i gotta
say it looks pretty cool
the way i ended up doing it but one of
the things that uh
that i think is really cool about the
film is there are a lot of practical
effects in the film it's not
it's not as cg heavy as you might expect
so you know
there is a there was a bit of puppetry
and a bit of like you know holding a
prosthetic heart and there was like they
were pumping it off screen and
so it was slippery you know so that sort
of
is um i think you can tell when you
watch the film but it was yeah
it wasn't exactly like i was acting
opposite of tennis ball i mean you were
it was happening in real time we were
watching it yeah it was amazing the the
intricacies of all of that and how much
effort they made it put into making it
real which was also
simon's vision he was like as little
green or blue screen as possible um
but yeah i mean the fatality is the best
i have a couple in there as well
i'd like to say i almost have one of the
most
you probably do well that is my time but
you are both fantastic and i love the
movie so much so congratulations
thank you thanks everyone